now tonight the numbers don't lie blue
states are deteriorating red states are
rising the new census data is in
and texas gained two house seats florida
gained one house seat
new york california they lost the seat
and in the case of the california it's
the first time they've lost a seat
since their statehood 170 years ago
great job gavin newsom take a bow what
does it all mean
it means americans are voting with their
feet and with their dollars and they are
saying
bye bye american pie to the liberal
socialist failures under the likes of
cuomo
and murphy and whitmer and newsom
and wolf and others florida texas they
have lower taxes less regulation
they're fully open they never adopted
those draconian measures on covid
they're reporting fewer covert cases
than democratic-led michigan
pennsylvania new york
etc and you know what else texas and
florida actually care about
safety and security of every american
and every community in their state
they're not interested in the democratic
dismantling and defunding of the police
take a look
defund the police abolish prisons
nancy pelosi and democrats in congress
have lost their minds
and now they're calling for violence
it's more confrontational
call congressman kind and tell him to
stand up to democrats attacks on law
enforcement
i'm sean hannity had nothing to do with
that ad and i approve it
anyway anyway it gets even worse for
democrats a new
mclaughlin poll is finding overwhelming
support
for voter id among likely voters and
even among those who say they approve of
biden
here with reaction fox news contributor
former speaker of the house newt
gingrich
i i mean it's the numbers speak for
themselves
right mr speaker i mean you've been
through a number of census over the
years
well let's start with the fact that
kevin mccarthy needs five seats
to become speaker david wasserman of the
cook report
analyzed this data during the day came
back and said
there's a very real chance that just out
of reapportionment
that the republicans will pick up eight
seats
which would be enough to knock out nancy
pelosi
and make kevin mccarthy the speaker
but there are deeper things going on as
you point out the
blue states are just hemorrhaging people
they're shoving them away and what's
crazy is in the middle of all this
the answer of the liberals is to raise
taxes so
you have everybody who's productive who
has resources
who pays taxes beginning to leave and
instead of trying to figure out how to
keep them
they're actually going to accelerate the
transition
out of the blue states to
the states that are run overwhelmingly
by republicans i mean
you've never seen a clearer contrast
between a high
tax big bureaucracy unionized
machine system in all of these states
run by democratic governors
and a free enterprise small business
entrepreneurship low tax system as we're
seeing in most
almost all the republican states and the
result is exactly what human nature
tells you
it would be people leave the pain they
go to the pleasure
and the migration is just going to
continue okay
so now the question is do blue states
get smart
because in new york they're now
proposing
the largest tax increases
in the history of any state in terms of
income taxes and
bureaucracy on top of what new york city
is adding to the state
which would bring now the federal income
tax level under biden
to 40 percent 15
new york state and city that's 55 cents
out of every dollar then the highest
property taxes in the country
okay how how dumb am i
if i do stay here i would argue i'm
pretty dumb
sean on your show i am about to write a
letter
saying bye bye new york
well look i i because of my great
affection for you
i don't want to contradict you so if you
want to say you're really dumb for
staying
i certainly don't want to disagree with
that
friendship you're like my older brother
thank you i really appreciate it
but here's what's fascinating you've got
in new york and in california
the two biggest uh democratic states
you have newsome in real trouble they've
qualified the
recall today and i happen to know that
uh he's right on the cusp of losing and
has been steadily losing ground
for the last couple months in new york
with somebody like lee zeldin running
you're going to have a lower tax
small business oriented job-creating
pro-police candidate and this may be the
best chance
republicans have to pick up the
governorship in new york
since governor pataki won back in 1994.
so
the very interesting changes underway i
was just told today for example
that the number two issue now in the new
york mayor's race is crime
and it's rising steadily and we're back
in a
pre-giuliani disastrous
area of crime and as that sinks in
the combination of crime being
anti-police
being pro-criminal being for huge
bureaucracies that don't work
and raising taxes real quick that could
come together in a way that
it's very you think do you think uh lee
zeldin or rob astorino
could win in new york and uh rick
rennell or caitlyn jenner could win
in california i don't i don't know if i
see it
well i certainly think that in new york
you have a real opportunity now
because you have such a clear case of
the system breaking down
particularly in new york city i think in
california
the odds are pretty remember the recall
is yes or no
if if newsom is under 50 percent
he's gone he's not in the runoff and at
that point
there will be a new governor and the
odds are pretty good it'll be a
republican
all right mr speaker thank you for being
with us hey sean hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else